MINUTE, SECOND OF EVERY DAY, NOW
IS NOT THE TIME TO LET UP.
LET US NOW BREAK IT ALL DOWN,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KARL ROVE.
I'M NOT SOMEBODY THAT EVER GETS
AHEAD OF AN ELECTION, WE BOTH
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECT
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECO
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELEC,
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECW
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECO
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECK
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECS
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECW
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECA
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECT
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECW
KNOW THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECL
COME OUT?
BUT IT IS CERTAINLY THE ECONOMY
AND HOW HARD LEFT THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE GONE, THEIR SLATE OF
CANDIDATES, HOW DO YOU SEE IT AT
LEAST -- WHEN IS THE BUILDING
ENTERING?
>> THAT WAS INTERESTING THAT
STEVE RATNER WHO IS NO FRIEND OF
DONALD TRUMP'S, HE WAS
BARACK OBAMA'S AUTO CZAR WROTE A
PIECE IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
POINTING OUT ALL OF THE MODELS
OF THE ELECTION ARE
FORECASTING A TRUMP
VICTORY.
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT WE HAVE TO
BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT THIS.
WE CANNOT GET OVERCONFIDENT.
WE CANNOT BELIEVE BECAUSE THE
MODELS PREDICT THAT TODAY THAT
THAT IS WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT OVER TIME, THE
ECONOMY AND WHO YOU VOTE FOR FOR
PRESIDENT IS A NONLINEAR
RELATIONSHIP.
THAT'S WHAT WE CALL IT AND
PULLING TERMS.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS AN INCUMBENT
ABSOLUTELY GETS PUNISHED FOR A
BAD ECONOMY.
IF YOU ARE HER OVERT HUMOR --
HERBERT HUMOR, YOU ARE BLAMED
FOR THE BAD ECONOMY,
PARTICULARLY IF YOU DO    DO NOT
PARTICULARLY IF YOU DO    DO NOU
PARTICULARLY IF YOU DO    DO NOE
TWO CRITICAL THINGS IN AN
ELECTION IS AN INCUMBENT, TALK
ABOUT YOUR SUCCESS, TALK ABOUT
THE NEXT STEP, AND DISQUALIFY
YOUR OPPONENT AS A THREAT TO
THAT ECONOMIC BIRTH.
CAN I GAVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE THAT
WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH?
>> Sean: YES.
THANK GOODNESS, WHERE IS THE
WHITEBOARD BACK?
>> UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN OCTOBER
OF 20,000 WAS 3.9%, NOW IT IS
3.6.
THE REAL GDP GROWTH IN 2000 WAS
2.97, GROWTH IN 2192.97.
THIS WAS THE CLINTON-GORE THIRD
ELECTION, THIS WAS AL GORE
RUNNING TO BE THE TERM OF
BILL CLINTON, IT WAS A GOOD
ECONOMY, IT WAS SLOWING DOWN, WE
WERE IN A RECESSION BY THE NEXT
MARCH, BUT IT WAS A GOOD ECONOMY
AS WE APPROACH THE ELECTION AND
THE I EYE CAN END UP TRICK
MODELS WERE FORECASTING A
VICTORY FOR AL GORE, BUT HE DID
NOT TALK ABOUT IT, HE SURE
AS HECK NEVER TALKED ABOUT WHAT
THE NEXT STEPS WERE FOR
CLINTON-GORE, AND HE NEVER
SUCCEEDED IN DISQUALIFYING
GEORGE W. BUSH, WHO PROACTIVELY
TALKED ABOUT WHAT WAS NECESSARY
TO SPREAD PROSPERITY MORE
BROADLY, WHICH WAS TO CUT THE
TAXES AND LOWER THE REGULATION
AND FOCUS ON TEACHING EVERY
CHILD TO LEARN TO READ.
SO WITH THE ELECTION IS ABOUT
WHATEVER THE CANDIDATES SAY IT
IS ABOUT AS LONG AS    AS A PEOL
IS ABOUT AS LONG AS    AS A PEOE
EXCEPTED, AND IF THE PRESIDENT
IS GOING TO USING ECONOMY TO HIS
ADVANTAGE.
IT HAS TO BE THOSE THREE THINGS.
TALK ABOUT IT, EXPLAIN THE NEXT
STEPS, AND DISQUALIFY THE
DEMOCRATIC APPROACH.
>> Sean: I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SEE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY UNITE
AND -- NATIONALIZE A SELECTION
AS A BID CHOICE ELECTION.
GREEN DEAL, THE MULLAHS IN IRAN,
OR THE TERM SUCCESS,
DEREGULATION, SAFETY AND
SECURITY FRAUD.
A SIMPLE.
>> SOMETIMES AN INCUMBENT ONE
SAID TO BE ABOUT LITTLE THINGS
PRINT PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD